what up space fam golden here from anime
uproar and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest
developments in the one piece story and
wow
what an amazing chapter we got here we
got kaido being shocked at luffy's
evolved devil fruit what looks like the
end of the luffy versus kaido battle
after so many chapters and much more so
make sure to stay tuned for this one if
you do enjoy these one-piece reviews and
want to keep them coming you know what
to do chill a pirate king within and
smash that like button with no mercy
always remember smashing his pirate king
energy and passing is scared orochi
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my huge and
growing one piece playlist that includes
videos on all the yonko admirals
supernova and much more link to that is
in the description and now without
further ado let's jump into it spoilers
and all this chapter is called winners
shouldn't need rationalizations which
implies this is already going to be a
pretty hyped chapter and we'll get more
into its significance when we get to
that part of the chapter we start off
strong with drake actually managing to
sneak up on the cp zero agent the
chapter starts with him already having
stabbed him oda toys with us a bit
suggesting that this might be it for the
agent he asks drake why as people tend
to do when it's over for them drake says
he is enacting his own justice and he
deserves respect for that my favorite
characters have their own sense of
justice like luffy and don't blindly
follow orders from the world government
the agent says that i quote i envy you
to drake and i personally feel like this
will be relevant as we learn more about
this dude he wants to be able to follow
his own justice or to just have his own
justice in the first place like drake
but clearly something is preventing him
which will no doubt be revealed as we
gather more info about him and his
backstory either way we have a turning
of the table situation being stabbed
with a sword doesn't saw our cp-0 agent
down in the least and he not only
escapes in a flash he delivers another
blow to drake which seems to be the
finishing one drake probably won't get
up again during this war but it was
necessary for him to do something here
drake going down without doing at least
this much would have been kind of sad
however how much this attack actually
slows down the cp-0 agent remains to be
seen clearly for the time being he's
still fast and deadly after this we got
the stark contrast of the battlefield
being juxtaposed to the celebration
below people are in a good mood and
making wishes using sky lanterns
including toko we know our guys are
fighting for all these people so once
more it shows us what's on the line we
then jump to the main event the fight
against luffy and kaido and wow kaido
can definitely take a punch or should i
say a million punches he just keeps
getting punched from all directions it's
hard to predict with luffy's countless
hydro punches where the next fist will
strike and even while kaido blocks one
he gets hit by another although luffy is
out of breath kaido does say the punch
is hurt with an exclamation mark which
is always high praise coming from ayanko
and the strongest creature he also says
something huge which has been touched
upon throughout the arc he says rubber
shouldn't be able to do this if this was
a one time thing we could say oda was
making fun of himself a bit for how much
creative license he's taken with the
rubber fruit but when we think about
everything else we learned throughout
the arc like about joy boy and the
importance of luffy's fruit it seems
clear this is yet another hype statement
telling us that luffy's fruit is special
not to mention luffy was special enough
to evolve or awaken it to this point and
such a statement also prepares us for
future power-ups which as kaido says may
move more and more beyond what rubber
should be able to do such comments
invite us to think of the legendary
fruit that hasn't awakened for centuries
that the five elders were discussing the
only one that was special enough for the
government to give it a unique name so
that they could hide the fruit's true
name from history in its initial forms
it may look like rubber but as it
awakens as mentioned it's bound to look
less and less like it after all these
clues i would be very surprised at this
point if this fruit in question didn't
turn out to be luffy's own so back to
the fight and luffy's more and more
awakening powers that even make a yonko
question them as if to quickly move on
from the huge statement kaido enters his
flirty drunk phase and tells luffy to
stop at you with a heart you know you're
a boss when you can be flirty against an
opponent who is trying their hardest to
finish you off again whatever happens
they made kaido very impressive during
this fight yeah luffy is getting
stronger and stronger and landing a
countless number of attacks but kaido is
fine and doing well drunk kaido talks
about how luffy is not the only one that
can see the future and then says he'll
take a page from luffy's book he starts
moving his body like luffy's punches the
dude is really showing off and again
doesn't seem phased by the onslaught of
attacks luffy launched kaido in dragon
form even bites and then quote unquote
eats luffy before spinning him out and
immediately launching a point-blank last
breath luffy enters bound man to deal
with the attack and bounce back to the
fighting field once more luffy
emphasized that his time is running out
he doesn't even know how many minutes
left he's got and says he doesn't have
time to waste kaido pours salt on the
wound saying luffy is in worse shape
than kairo even thought it is already
not looking well luffy says he can't
lose here everyone in wano will continue
to starve and go thirsty if kaido sticks
around kaido laughs at luffy for joining
forces with the people of wano who are
used to defeat he says they are either
weak pacifists or content to die for the
sake of honor another reference to the
samurai being too ready to die instead
of finding a way to keep living and keep
fighting luffy says shut up getting
pretty defensive and says the samurai
are strong and of course it depends on
your definition of strength for kaido a
brave face aka being stoic in the face
of adversity doesn't make people strong
he says winners shouldn't need
rationalizations which are you a winner
or a loser and that actually reminds me
of a high q episode i watched yesterday
where a player was trying to find a
reason to get excited about the idea of
winning in volleyball and another
character said who needs a reason to
want to win or to not want to lose for
kaido luffy's statement of he can't lose
for the sake of the people of wano is
unnecessary for kaido he just wants to
win to win and you can talk all about
honor he says and rationalize why the
samurai is supposedly strong but if they
can't win the fight then they're still
losers in his eyes although how much he
truly believes in this cut and drive
philosophy will soon be questioned for
now luffy launches supreme kong gun and
it's another satisfying panel showing
what looks like kaido taking a lot of
damage luffy goes in to attack again but
is surprised to see kaido has recovered
quickly and launches an attack of his
own sending luffy to the ground whited
out eyes and everything he starts the
exhaling process but then covers his
mouth thinking he can't let any escape
or he'll lose power so luffy is at the
edge barely still going and kaido is
fine and smiling as he enters his
homicidal drunk phase for this reason it
seems like luffy needs another gear or
form he needs to get the awakening that
was hinted at last chapter with that
crazy cool silhouette the hope is when
he expends all he's got he'll be able to
tap into something deeper and bounce
back again but we'll see one thing's
clear even if he keeps going like this
which it doesn't even appear like he can
it still hasn't been enough to slow
kaido down or to even wipe the smile
from his face and so i can't see this
version of luffy finishing things off
for now luffy says one more shot if this
isn't enough i'll lose again reiterating
how bad luffy's situation appears but
it's hype too because it seems like
it'll end with both fighters using as
much energy and power they can muster in
one hit but then just as we're expecting
that insane epic clash the cp-0 agent
interrupts luffy's attack meaning that
kaido just went full out on a helpless
luffy and it was point-blank range even
though kaido was saying it's all about
winners and losers before it's clear
that he's upset cp 0 interfered he
recalls when odin was tricked by the old
lady who transformed into momo and how
kaido won because of that unfair
advantage he had the lady killed that's
how upset he was and it probably even
contributed to his drinking more i'd say
his lack of honor in that situation
really haunted him because he went on to
execute odin instead of giving him
another shot and now with all the
emotionally amplified effects of alcohol
it looks like it just happened all over
again will he try to write his wrongs
from the past here will he go after a cp
0 agent which seems like the obvious
move after he went after the lady last
time will he let luffy go because of the
interference in direct contrast to how
he executed odin or and this is my hope
will luffy bounce back stronger than
ever with a new gear or awakened form
although i hope it's not the case this
fight could potentially be over here
since luffy said he was at his limit and
he just got hit point blank by kaido's
attack if it is over i don't think kaido
would finish him off since he definitely
feel bad for the interference this whole
arc has been preparing us for this
moment but at the same time i feel like
this has to be settled here since we
can't have luffy face kaido again
sometime down the line after all this
build up and after all these chapters
let me know your thoughts here all i
know is that i'm very excited for the
next chapter in fact i can't remember
the last time i was more excited than
this for the next chapter that is it for
this one obviously mvp goes to luffy for
me but if kaido beats the cp-0 agent
next chapter and lets luffy recover then
next chapter mvp is going to kaido since
that will show a lot of growth in the
dude's character after all that time
spent denying honor if you did enjoy
this review and want to keep them coming
you know what to do channel power king
within and smash that like button with
no mercy always remember smashing is
pirating energy and passing is scared of
rochi energy so choose wisely if you
haven't make this the video subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications or you will miss
future one-piece videos and updates and
while you wait for the next chapter to
drop feel free to check out my huge and
growing one-piece playlist that includes
videos not the yonko admirals supernova
and much more link to that is in the
description and until next time see ya
space cowboys